[Music]
foreign
[Music]
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month the 90s were a decade when
technology and entertainment soared to
inconceivable Heights the cast of
Friends felt like family Nickelodeon
slimed and Humanity welcomed the most
revolutionary advancement since
telephones no not Furbies the World Wide
Web one year in particular gave rise to
innovators like Amazon and Yahoo while a
boxing champion sold us a grill that
knocks out the fat Disney couldn't wait
to be king and Jim Carrey would star in
three Blockbusters in a row so what was
it about this year that will forever
leave its Mark in Hollywood and pop
culture history let's take a trip down
memory lane to find out here's your year
on review 1994 Edition
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
of what would become a three film
franchise and an animated series Jim
Carrey plays Ace Ventura a wacky hair
detective tasked with finding a recently
kidnapped Miami Dolphins mascot a
bottlenose named Snowflake here's
snowflake
I've got a little snack for you
hell is a series of clues that compel
him to plunge his own phase and SOB in
the shower hey buddy we've all been
there do not go in there whoa despite
Roger Ebert writing that he found the
movie a long unfunny slog through an
impenetrable plot Ace Ventura Pet
Detective was a box office win grossing
107 million dollars worldwide on a 15
million dollar budget what do you want
what HDs sir and how are you this
afternoon all
sounds broken most likely sir I'll bet
it was something nice though critics say
Jim Carrey's Twitchy Antics and gross
out humor are on full bombastic display
in Ace Ventura Pet Detective which is
great news for fans of his particular
brand of Comedy but likely unsatisfying
for anyone else
foreign
[Music]
smoking I can smell it on your breath I
was not smoking you can't accuse me of
something I wasn't even doing oh yeah
then you were sucking on the bottom of
an ashtray like some pathetic and
disgusting nicotine junkie that's better
we all know Jason Alexander as George
from Seinfeld but did you know that he
also voiced the lead role in an animated
series called duck man
jerk
who are you calling jerky long hair fat
belly goofy tattooed 60s throwback
Village People want to be biker freak
Eric's Tiberius duck man to be precise
is a widowed self-loathing egomaniac
okay maybe that's not far off from
George only Duckman works as an LA based
pi and is in fact a duck the show first
appeared on the USA Network and featured
a who's who list of celebrity guests
like Ben Stiller Janine Garofalo and
countless others Everett Peck's creation
went on to earn several Emmy nominations
in its Four Seasons 70 episode run and
became a precursor to shows like Family
Guy and BoJack Horseman we're not even
ashamed to be sitting with you when
you're picking at your underwear in
public ah yes well High Praise indeed
let me say how gratifying it is to hear
it for all I ever wanted to be was an
ideal role model a shining example of
some of my children could look up to
critics say clever and crude duck man's
particular brand of adult humor may not
be for everyone but those looking to
laugh at the misery of life will find
comfort in its bizarrely brilliant if
not borderline nihilistic commentary
with this ring Ivy wed
with this ring I the word with my body I
Thee worship
with my body I Thee worship and with all
my worldly Goods sight of thee endow and
with all my worldly Goods I Thee and
thou
hmm adorned with some Winsome
performances and perfectly placed
one-liners Four Weddings and a funeral
is a tale of friendship and fortuitous
romance centered around you guessed it
some weddings and a funeral this R-rated
British rom-com would slingshot the
careers of Hugh Grant Kristen Scott
Thomas and director Mike Newell produced
with fun so tight that extras were
forced to bring their own wedding attire
to set the film went on to fully
transform British Cinema placing 23rd on
the bfi's 100 greatest British films of
the 20th century with a modest budget of
4 million dollars Newell's critically
acclaimed hit grossed a staggering 245
million globally it took writer Richard
Curtis 17 drafts to reach a final
version of this script critics say well
frothy to a fault Four Weddings and a
funeral features irresistibly Breezy
humor and Winsome performances from Hugh
Grant and Andy McDowell
foreign
[Music]
based on the animated TV series of the
same name The Flintstones is a
live-action family comedy starring John
Goodman Rosie O'Donnell Rick Moranis and
Elizabeth Taylor in what would be the
Oscar winners final movie performance
[Music]
day of his life he lived in a ripe old
age of 38. director Brian Levant takes
us back to prehistoric Suburban Bedrock
we follow the age-old shenanigans of
Fred Flintstone and Barney Rubble as
they become embroiled in the Twisted
business games of cliff vandercave and
Sharon Stone no not the casino actress
critics had a real bone to pick with
this one and it went on to win two
razzies for Worse supporting actress and
worse screenplay
Flintstones and rubbles Under One Roof
yeah but Fred you know it's only
temporary it better be
better
despite the stone cold reception The
Flintstones gross 342 million dollars
worldwide critics say The Flintstones
waste beloved Source material and
imaginative production design on a tepid
script that plunks bedrock's favorite
family into a cynical story a wash with
lame puns
[Music]
somewhere between bouts with Surfer
gangs and armies of agent Smiths Keanu
Reeves starred as Jack travin an LA
police officer attempting to save a
busload of hostages from a wired
explosive device but here's the kicker
if the bus drops below the speed of 50
miles per hour then it's whoa game over
thank you
Dennis Hopper plays a conceivingly
deranged villain but the most notable
performance comes from a young Sandra
Bullock in her career driving role of
Annie Porter the film was Jan to Bond's
directorial debut earning two Academy
Awards critical and Commercial Success
critics say a terrific popcorn Thriller
speed is taught tense and energetic with
outstanding performances from Keanu
Reeves Dennis Hopper and Sandra Bullock
Pumbaa come over here
now look this is Pumbaa Pumbaa now at
least to make your acquaintance I choose
all mine how do you do whoa whoa time
out let me get this straight you know
her she knows you but she wants to eat
him and everybody's okay with this
did I miss something it's the circle of
life and it moved us all directly to the
ticket windows that summer The Lion King
became the highest grossing film of the
year earning an astounding
312.9 million domestically and 850
million worldwide who knew that singing
felines were a foolproof recipe for
global domination what's that oh it
didn't work for cats oops Disney's
30-second animated film boasts expert
voice Talent from James Earl Jones
Matthew Broderick Moira Kelly Jonathan
Taylor Thomas Jeremy Irons Whoopi
Goldberg and Cheech Marin to name a few
the legacy of The Lion King prances on
with a direct-to-video sequel a spin-off
movie a Broadway musical and a 2019 CGI
remake
hey wake up
yeah
it's okay wow wow it's okay
oh don't ever do that again
carnivores uh critics say emotionally
stirring richly drawn and beautifully
animated The Lion King is a pride within
Disney's Pantheon of classic family
films
[Music]
run forest run moving on to the next
summer smash Robert zemeckis's
allegorical film stars Tom Hanks as
Forest Gump a below average IQ
sweetheart who recounts his life story
to strangers at a bus stop in Savannah
Georgia co-star Robin Wright plays Jenny
The elusive love interest that inspires
Forrest to run Forrest run his way into
his slew of triumphs and tribulations
screenwriter Eric Roth Chronicles
important junctures in American history
as seen and lived by the protagonist
it's no surprise that in 2009 the film
was selected for preservation in the
library of congress's national film
registry citing its cultural historical
and aesthetic significance in film
what's my destiny mom
you're gonna have to have to view that
out for yourself
life is a box of chocolates fullest
you never know what you're gonna get
mama always had a way of explaining
things so I could understand them
Forrest Gump took home six Academy
Awards and was the second highest
grossing film of 1994. critics say
Forrest Gump may be an overly
sentimental film with a somewhat
problematic message but it's sweetness
and charm are usually enough to
approximate true depth and Grace
foreign
I was in the area and I thought that you
made one day of lunch
became the first film in history with a
production budget of over 100 million
dollars though if anyone was going to
break that record it would be James
Cameron the film stars Arnold as Harry
Tasker a secret spy leading a double
life under the guise of a Salesman a
Salesman really look look at the guy the
plot erupts when Harry's wife Helen
Jamie Lee Curtis is kidnapped by an
Islamic jihadist in possession of
nuclear missiles it's not like he's
saving the world or anything I mean he's
sales rep for Christ's sake whenever I
can't sleep I just asked him to tell me
about his day six seconds and I'm out
when he acts like he's curing cancer or
something the film earned Curtis a
Golden Globe and a Saturn Award for best
actress and ultimately gross 378 million
dollars worldwide critics say if it
doesn't reach the heights of director
James Cameron's and star Arnold
Schwarzenegger's previous collaborations
True Lies still packs enough action and
humor into its sometimes absurd plot to
entertain
thank you
foreign
Carrie's epical year slides along as he
embodies Stanley ipkiss a timid Bank
clerk who stumbles upon a magical mask
that unlocks the spirit of the Norse god
Loki with the mask on Stanley oozes
superhuman charm and confidence which
catches the eye of a dazzling nightclub
singer played by Cameron Diaz in her
film debut unfortunately the masked
Maniac proves to be Troublesome when he
Robs a Bank and quite literally loses
sight of his former self the eyeball
glasses I've never seen those before in
my life
bazooka I have a permit for that
picture of Callaway's wife what oh
Margaret
son of a [ __ ] jeez I figured you had a
sense of humor after all
you marry her
get him earning an impressive 350
million dollars on a budget of 23
million the mask was a commercial
success and became the second most
profitable comic-based film up to that
point critics say it misses perhaps as
often as it hits but Jim Carrey's manic
bomb ass Cameron Diaz's blousey appeal
and the film's overall cartoony bombast
keeps the mask afloat
[Music]
I'd really like to know what it was that
made it so incredibly boring just tell
me was it was it is it too emotional too
personal too many big words shut up
bravely tackling social issues like
child abuse teenage alcoholism
homophobia and school violence my
so-called life is unanimously hailed as
one of television's greatest series
created by Winnie Holzman the show ran
on ABC for just one season yet it
launched the career of Oscar winner
Jared Leto and earned Claire Danes a
Golden Globe at age 15. critics say
effectively avoiding cliche and cheesy
Exposition my so-called life's realistic
portrayal of the average American Girl
is ahead of its time
this next gem needs no introduction
unless you just escaped your own version
of The Truman Show in which case we
should probably explain all the masks
Pulp Fiction is one of the most
influential films of the 90s and
arguably ever this time jumping neo-noir
crime drama is credited with Reviving
John Travolta's career and making Global
stars of Samuel L Jackson and Uma
Thurman
what country are you from what what
ain't no country I ever heard of they
speak English and what
what English [ __ ] do you speak
it yes then you know what I'm saying
describe what Marcellus Wallace looks
like
what it's like what again say what again
I dare you I double dare you
[ __ ] say what one more God times
the film won the Palm door at the 1994
canned Film Festival was nominated for
seven Oscars winning for best original
screenplay and like Forrest Gump was
selected for preservation in the United
States national film registry did we
mention that at the time it was made it
was the top grossing independent film
ever made earning 214 million dollars
worldwide against a budget of just 8.5
million critics say one of the most
influential films of the 1990s Pulp
Fiction is a Delirious post-modern mix
of neo-noir Thrills pitch black humor
and pop culture touchstones
Mr Stevens has a birth certificate
driver's license social security number
if they ever Trace any of those accounts
they're going to wind up chasing a
figment of my imagination
did I say you were good
you're a Rembrandt
and the funny thing is
on the outside I was an honest man
straight is narrow
I had to come to prison to be a crook
ah years before developing The Walking
Dead Frank darabon wrote and directed
The Shawshank Redemption starring Tim
Robbins and based on the Stephen King
Novella it's the fictitious story of
Andy Dufresne a banker sentenced to life
in Shawshank Penitentiary for two
murders he didn't commit while in prison
Dufresne befriends Ellis red reading and
astute Contraband Smuggler brilliantly
portrayed by Morgan Freeman
could you add this to your outgoing mail
I'd be happy to
though some critics scoffed at the 142
minute running time the film was
reviewed favorably and earned seven
Oscar nods though it didn't take any
home maybe they should have just snuck
one out in a Bible critics say the
Shawshank Redemption is an uplifting
deeply satisfying prison drama with
sensitive Direction and fine
performances
don't tell me don't tell me
decaf cappuccino for Joey
coffee black
latte
[Laughter]
and a nice tea I'm getting pretty good
at this excellent
good for me
bet you can't think of the show Friends
without getting that jangly theme song
stuck in your head
[Music]
you're welcome creators David Crane and
Marta Kaufman first pitched their seven
page treatment under the working titles
insomnia Cafe six of one and friends
like us before ultimately deciding on
the more concise version we know today
the series was Infamous for its
celebrity cameos which included Brad
Pitt Kristen Davis Alec Baldwin Brad
Pitt Dakota Fanning Winona Ryder and
also Brad Pitt God will I'm so glad that
you came you just you look great you
must have lost like 150 pounds yeah I'm
gonna be one of the Subway sandwich
commercials
with six prime time Emmy wins a 10
season 236 episode run and a 2021 cast
reunion viewed by millions friends goes
down in history as one of television's
Pinnacle achievements
[Music]
that is exactly why you want a high
quality fire extinguisher right in the
kitchen
those Flames were really big dad
funny that way
hey
what better way to ring in the holidays
than to accidentally kill Santa and
steal his job sprinkle in a few elves
rapid obesity a divorce turned custody
battle and you've got the makings of
John pasquin's the Santa Claus how Jolly
the film stars Tim Allen is Scott an
ordinary man who morphs into Old Saint
Nicholas but soon realizes he's bitten
off more candy cane than he can chew
on
look comment like I said there is
nothing left
that's so weird because I know when I
did that no no no no no hold it there's
no chimney here can you hear me no
chimney all right
[Music]
got to be
to be first of a financially fruitful
Trilogy that our essential Christmas
Time Entertainment critics say the Santa
Claus is utterly undemanding but it's
firmly rooted in the sort of good
old-fashioned holiday spirit missing
from too many modern Yuletide films it
will not be deactivated
got an officer on board the ship and I
require you to perform your duty that is
an order Commander
search egg Generations is the seventh
film in the Sci-Fi franchise that
continues to live long and prosper
starring The Immortal Patrick Stewart
and William Shatner it Bridges the
Galaxy between the OG cast and the Next
Generation newcomers DP John Alonso
known for Chinatown and Scarface steals
the show and what critics hailed as
crystalline cinematography which makes
Generations the most beautiful Trek ever
captain of the neighborhood
close to retirement
I'm not planning on it let me tell you
something
don't
don't let them promote you
don't let them transfer you don't let
them do anything
that takes you off the bridge of that
ship because while you're there
you can make a difference
back with me
make a difference
the film opened at the top of the U.S
box office in its first week and went on
to gross 118 million dollars worldwide
critics say generation stands as a
mediocre Changing of the Guard for the
crews of the Enterprise with a dull plot
that sometimes seems like an expanded
episode of the television series
foreign hey
I want to hear the most annoying sound
in the world
[Music]
fellas
you think we could
listen to the radio or something
radio
who needs a radio gentleman Dumber tells
the tale of idiots Lloyd and Harry as
they embark on a cross-country trip to
Aspen all in the name of returning a
cash-filled suitcase to Mary swamps slip
slippy sloppy Simon Swenson Samsonite I
was way off
what do you think the chances are of uh
a guy like you and a girl like me
ending up together
well Lloyd that's difficult to say and
we really don't hit me with it just give
it to me straight I came a long way just
to see you Mary just
at least you can do is level with me
what are my chances
not good
you mean not good like one out of a
hundred I'd say
more like one out of a million
so you're telling me there's a chance
yeah Peter Farley directed and co-wrote
the script with his brother Bobby and
thanks to a worldwide gross of 247
million dollars Dumb and Dumber would be
the first of many victories for the
comedy duo critics say a relentlessly
stupid comedy elevated by its main
actors Jim Carrey goes Bonkers and Jeff
Daniel carries himself admirably in an
against type performance
so who are you staring at uh you
at uh what game were you playing
I don't know but I think I won finally
after a year of male focused films we
wrap things up with Jillian Armstrong's
version of alcott's Little Women the
film features an all-female leading cast
that includes Winona Ryder Trini
Alvarado Claire Danes Kirsten Dunst and
Susan Sarandon going against an industry
that producer Denise denovie felt wasn't
interested in a movie with a lot of
women it took the film an unnerving 12
years to find a studio critics and
audiences will agree that it was well
worth the wait Little Women was
nominated for three Academy Awards made
95 million dollars and was seen by many
as the definitive movie Take on the book
until Greta gerwig's adaptation in 2019
which she absolutely deserved the Oscar
for critics say thanks to a Powerhouse
lineup of talented actresses Jillian
Armstrong's take on Louisa May alcott's
Little Women proves that a Timeless
story can succeed no matter how many
times it's told
there you have it our highlights for a
year that still pulls its weight in the
modern world of streaming and Tick Tock
of course we couldn't include every
notable release in 1994 but you can
thank Jim Carrey for hogging all the
attention
somebody stop me